si vous êtes en panne d'inspiration pour
vos cadeaux cette année les jeux en bois
il jeu mécanique reste une valeur sûre
les jouets à tirer et puis des grands
classiques comme comme des puzzles et
jeux de construction etc
il n'y a pas forcément de grosses
nouveautés cette année dans ce magasin
ne mord pas depuis quelques jours les
parents s'occupent déjà de la liste de
leurs enfants
et malgré la crise il continue de
remplir la hotte du père noël pour le 25
décembre
en fait les autres ont pas de cadeau
mais mes enfants auront des cadeaux
c'est souffert les autres ils auront
moins de cadeaux quoi vous privilégié
quand même les enfants oui je pense
c'est autour de 70 euros par enfant il
n'y aura pas forcément de nouveauté
cette année sous le sapin
mais le cadeau très tendance c'est la
tablette tactile le contenu est adapté
aux enfants vous avez à l'intérieur du
contenu ludo éducatif
vous allez avoir des activités pour les
enfants qui sont en rapport avec la vie
de tous les jours pour apprendre des
petites recettes de cuisine des jeux de
récréation des petits pour de bricolage
à côté du cadeau technologie chez les
filles la mode est aux vampires et aux
petits monstres
à côté des classiques poupées et costume
de princesse
chez les garçons les éternels jeux de
construction restent dans le top des
ventes et les toupies devrait être
encore nombreuses sur les listes un
produit populaire qui est déjà en
rupture de stock
c'est sur ce fauteuil que le père noël
accueillera les enfants tout le mois de
décembre une période pendant laquelle
les spécialistes du jouet réalise 50% de
leur chiffre d'affaires annuel